I want to start today talking about
patriotism we've seen some of the worst
aspects of the sword of George W Bush
neocon Republicans exacerbated or blown
up under the trumpian America in which
we live and patriotism is definitely at
the top of that list and if you've been
following politics American politics for
any length of time you know that
Republicans for a long time have tried
to co-opt the term patriotism for their
own gain and not only have they sought
to define patriotism they've
specifically done it in a way to try to
monopolize patriotism in American
society where the Republicans are
patriotic and Democrats and socialists
and everybody else is not but this has
gotten even worse during the era of
Donald Trump and you might remember back
when george w bush was president
Republicans tried to weaponize the idea
of patriotism to say you know if you
don't support the troops in Iraq you're
not patriotic and of course people like
me who opposed sending troops to Iraq we
opposed it because it was misguided as a
response to Saudis attacking us on 9/11
it didn't make any sense and so when we
opposed going into Iraq it was because
we support the troops and we want our
country to do the right things we didn't
want to send troops into harm's way for
a misguided and politically motivated
military engagement based on then flimsy
and after the fact we knew completely
bogus so-called intelligence but we were
called unpatriotic as a result of that
cut to the Trump era we are now seeing
something very similar but because
Donald Trump's followers just like on
average Trump's followers seem even less
informed and less intelligent than those
of George W Bush if that can be believed
it's working in an even more insidious
way
so remember patriotism is devotion to
one's country whereas nationalism is
more about focusing support
on the interests of one's country even
at the exclusion or to the detriment of
other countries right so patriotism
versus nationalism there's a difference
and there's overlap when we talk about
patriotism we're really talking about
devotion and attachment to one's country
and an alliance with our fellow citizens
we're not talking when we say patriotism
of blind loyalty to the President or
blind loyalty to the military or the
President or the military or our leaders
actions and that's how the trumpets are
trying to define patriotism for their
benefit if you look at the data on the
virus and you come to the only sane and
logical conclusion which is wow we have
failed miserably on the virus where most
other countries have done better than we
have we have failed they will say that's
unpatriotic noticing that is unpatriotic
what we're doing is recognizing we can
do better
wanting to do better there is nothing
unpatriotic about that and you can't
don't allow them to frame it that way
they want you to believe that wanting
your country to do better and believing
it could have done better is unpatriotic
that's laughable and we can't allow them
to do that that's what they want to
convince you of and when you step back
the way in which patriotism or attacks
of lack of patriotism are weaponized by
trumpets fit this description in a
number of ways look at the wall as an
example when it comes to the wall they
want to build a wall between the u.s.
and Mexico they insist it's patriotic to
do so why we are allowed to question
that why is it patriotic most people
coming to the United States illegally
are not crossing the physical border
they're overstaying visas the wall can
be defeated it's outrageously expensive
it won't improve relationships with
other countries to sort of deal with the
immigration issue at its core so why is
it unpatriotic to question the wall it's
not but they use that assertion to shut
down debate they want you to believe
maybe it is
unpatriotic to question the wall so that
you shut your mouth it's essentially an
ad hominem they will make the debt we've
talked about this one before
odet oh it's a terrible when a
Democratic president is in the Oval
Office debt is an issue of patriotism
and then when a president takes over
who's a Republican and explodes the debt
like Bush did like Trump has debt
doesn't matter anymore it's no longer an
issue of patriotism the right loves to
say that when we on the Left say that's
racist they say you can't talk about
that you should feel bad that you called
someone a racist
they make finding racism the problem in
order to stifle debate and they're using
the term patriotism in the exact same
way they say you're being unpatriotic
that's on American and they do it to
make the conversation about whether you
are a patriot rather than evaluating the
criticism have we done well on
coronavirus or haven't we we look at the
numbers we figure it out it's
unpatriotic you're not standing by the
country because you're not standing by
the president well the president failed
nothing unpatriotic about that so here's
my warning to you we need to treat
allegations about lack of patriotism the
same way we should treat allegations of
Trump derangement syndrome I told you
this last week there's these
catchphrases and tools that they have
developed to actually shut down debate
and they claim they're about debate they
don't want to suppress speech they claim
but they use these terms
you're unpatriotic that's Trump
derangement syndrome to shame and
ridicule anybody who wants to make a
critique it's very popular on Twitter
now you make any criticism of Donald
Trump the reactions will be you have TDS
Trump you have TDS Trump derangement
syndrome orange man bad can't you do
anything other than orange man bad this
is the idea that you are blinded by
hatred of Trump where you can't
logically critique him and then they
just ignore the critique they don't
actually think about what you're saying
because you have trumped arrangment
syndrome don't allow them to stifle the
debate with these questions when they
say that's unpatriotic say what is
unpatriotic about it well you're not
standing by the president patriotism is
about what's best for the country and
our fellow citizens it is not about
blind loyalty to whoever happens to
occupy the Oval Office for four or eight
years and just remember way
there's always hypocrisy when Obama was
president and Trump was starting to
dabble more and more in politics Trump
spent years criticizing Obama and now
they want to say criticizing the
president that's unpatriotic so don't
fall for it patriotism is wanting what's
best for your country and the people in
the country it is not blind loyalty to
Trump it's not blind loyalty to the
military or to any president that's more
how cults work and that's increasingly
what the Trump administration and the
Trump Ian milieu actually represents not
liberal democracies so don't fall for it
guys it's getting really really bad
April and May we're seemingly nothing
when it comes to coronavirus compared to
what it is we are increasingly facing
right now we are seeing new coronavirus
records almost daily and these are not
the types of records you want to be
setting remember that for the Trump
administration we beat this thing in May
it's over I mean we're months past
victory now it's true that other
countries did almost beat this thing
they are reopening safely they've
crushed their curve and life is looking
more and more normal and it's true that
parts of the US are reopened almost
completely but those parts of the US are
seeing some of the worst outbreaks in
the world if Florida or Arizona were
countries alone they would be some of
the worst countries in the world to be
in from the standpoint of coronavirus so
let's just look at the data Florida
yesterday set the all-time high ever for
any single day new cases in any of the
50 US states Florida had more than
15,000 new cases yesterday this is way
worse this is thousands more than even
New York had at the worst point in its
outbreak I was what it's making global
headlines
how bad things are in Florida I was
watching Argentinian news this morning
and they said breaking news the United
States state of Florida set a record
we've never seen anywhere meanwhile on
Friday in the US again I've been saying
this type of thing for months because it
keeps getting worse the u.s. set the
single day record for cases with almost
72,000 cases in one day there are now a
record estimated 1.75 million active
cases in the United States almost three
and a half million cumulative cases and
then the deaths you know we were hoping
I was cautiously optimistic that
something different would happen that
even though the case has started spiking
around June 19 that deaths would not
spike 20 days later but sadly right on
cue 20 days after the case has spiked we
saw last Monday Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday deaths back up to the 752 a
thousand per day range and it is
believed that those deaths are tied to
the cases from around June 20 to 25
early July was way worse in terms of
cases and if indeed we're going to see
the same pattern next week is going to
be very very ugly so there are about
three layers of I'm disappointing that's
not really the word three layers of
dismay here when it comes to what's
going on first we know the
administration failed they don't seem to
care Trump is golfing he's not talking
to foul Chee I'll tell you about that
later that's number one we know it could
have gone better because just about
every other country did better the proof
is there there's nothing unique about
the you know they'll say well these
other countries are less free than the
United States no they're more smart
South Korea ranks higher on the
democracy index than the United States
when you hear the only reason South
Korea did what they did is because they
they're not free the way we are
according to the democracy index South
Korea is more free than the United
States second we are in this situation
partially because of the administration
yeah that's true but partially we're in
the situation we are because of
governors and the people in the states
now that's on both sides what I mean by
that is Trump failed that's the the
starting point
in some states governors and people took
things seriously I'm not you know some
people say I brag about Massachusetts
I've privileged to live in a wealthy
state like Massachusetts listen I just
know what's going on here you see masks
everywhere schools were closed almost
all summer camps other than some very
specific you know physically distant
camps that are possible
utmost caution here and in fact people
are getting worried that we're doing too
much by by letting restaurants do indoor
dining I don't think we should in other
states
people who think masks and vaccines are
the problem are sort of joining forces
with ignorant governors to let the
situation run rampant
so that's horrifying that's the second
piece which is that as Trump failing
aside you have a dramatically different
population in different parts of the
country and different governors who have
handled this very differently and you
can see it in the case numbers and then
number three of course is that we've
done so little but we're pretending like
it was just beyond our control
that's a very disturbing attitude you
just look at other countries we chose to
handle this differently than other
countries
some states did it one way some states
that in another way but we're almost
saying we're all out of ideas except
we've done almost nothing and they're
looking at reopening Disney World when
Florida got 15,000 new cases in a single
day
it's truly vile and all we can do is you
know one of the tough things for me has
been relinquish inquiry I never had
control but recognizing that I just lack
the control to really affect this at the
big picture all I can do is okay I've
chosen to live in a state that I
predicted would handle things well
generally speaking and I'm lucky in that
sense and I live in Massachusetts I can
wear my mask I can be safe I can tell
people what I think makes sense to do I
can't control everything I can't control
the vaccines and that's a really tough
thing right now for people who see how
we've gone wrong from day one
tomorrow night please join the David
Pakman show third David Pakman show
chess tournament 8:00 p.m. Eastern
Tuesday July 14 I will be playing
everybody can play register
for free at david pakman.com slash chess
I will also livestream my participation
and secondly tomorrow same day Tuesday
July 14 we will do be doing a big
one-day membership special we're trying
to dig out of a 300 member hole that
happened on July 4th when a bunch of
2019 members had to cancel because of
the virus so we're gonna try to dig out
of that tomorrow with a one-day
membership special if you want to be
notified about it very easy just go to
david pakman.com and get on my
newsletter get sign up for the
newsletter you'll see where to type in
your email address on the right side of
the website tomorrow you'll get a
beautiful email from me telling you how
to take advantage of this discount in
the meantime tell me how things are
looking in your state i'm on twitter at
a Pakman the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
the David Pakman show
depends on your support and the easiest
way is through membership which includes
the world-famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show just for members sign up
today at join pakman.com coupon code
saves you 40% vote soon 18 the david
pakman show at david pakman.com today's
new members of the day are Daniel Saito
and Elaine May Daniel and Elaine thank
you so much for your support and I also
want to thank Jonathan white jonathan
has been a member for almost 5 years and
as today's longtime sustainer of the day
thanks Jonathan grab a membership at
join pakman.com a lot of good stuff
happening on the members only bonus show
today one of the most popular perks of
being a member
Donald Trump has commuted the sentence
of his campaign associate Roger stone
Roger stone therefore will not be going
to prison where he was scheduled to
report soon now
there's the general discussion here and
then there's the specific discussion and
I think it makes sense to go in that
order in general when presidents
pardoned people or commute their
sentences it's very common that red
flags come up about connections between
the presidents and the people they are
pardoning or whose sentences they're
commuting a were they friends or
whatever the case may be in this case
Trump is commuting the sentence not just
of a friend to the extent that Donald
Trump has friendships but of a friend
who worked to get Donald Trump elected
but it isn't just that it's a friend
whose crime was directly related to
helping to get Donald Trump elected but
it's even more the reason that Roger
stone lied in relation to his work
getting Donald Trump elected was to
protect Trump by hiding wrongdoing that
Donald Trump may
been involved in and in comes Donald
Trump and commutes Roger stones sentence
this is exactly as Republican senator
Mitt Romney of all people said it is
historic corruption Roger stone was a
go-between for the Trump campaign and
WikiLeaks Roger stone was materially
involved in the Trump campaign Roger
stone was convicted by a jury for lying
to Congress to protect Donald Trump so
this is corruption this is an abuse of
power this is a quid pro quo remember
that phrase that Trump threw around to
stay strong when it was Paul Manafort
and Michael Cohen Trump's former
campaign chairman and former personal
lawyer who were under investigation and
under indictment Donald Trump tweeted
about mana Ford is staying strong what
that means is he's protecting Donald
Trump well Roger stones stayed strong in
that vein he didn't roll over he didn't
talk about what Trump knew and what
Trump did and that is a quid pro quo
this is arguably a form of bribery this
is arguably an impeachable offense now
Trump and others will argue and it's
important to be prepared for this they
will say the president's power to pardon
and commute sentences is absolute
yeah it's absolute in that a president
can pardon whoever they want to pardon
or commute the sentence sentence of
whoever they want to commute a sentence
for but that doesn't mean that it can't
also be an act of corruption or a quid
pro quo or a form of bribery and only to
Republicans so far have actually called
this out for what it is one is MIT
Romney as I mentioned MIT Romney tweeted
quote unprecedented historic corruption
an American president commutes the
sentence of a person convicted by a jury
of lying to shield that very president
now you know good for Mitt Romney
but remember Romney voted to convict
Trump on one impeachment count but he
voted to acquit Donald Trump on
obstruction and now MIT Romney is
indignant that Donald Trump is again
obstructing give me a break
so I get at MIT Romney
saying things most Republicans aren't
willing to say but at the same time you
acquitted the guy on obstruction you
remember that right then you have
Republican Senator Pat Toomey who said
that the prosecution of Roger stone was
a righteous and appropriate prosecution
quoting what William bar had to say and
that if there was a problem with this
prosecution it really should be resolved
via an appeal not between not by Donald
Trump jumping in and commuting the
sentence of Roger stone if Sohn was
treated unfairly in a real sense but we
are well within the scope of time during
which an appeal can be made and it could
actually be fought through the courts so
the action by Trump here is not
surprising the realization that we've
come to is that until Republicans are
forced to do what's right or stopped
from doing what's wrong they're going to
keep doing it and we're you know I think
maybe there's not that much I have to
say about stone specifically I think
it's basically all being been said but
what sometimes happens in these
situations is that some on the left will
start saying should we stoop to their
level like are they so bad that we
should resort to cheating or violence or
corruption in order to get them out does
the ends do the ends justify the means
and I don't believe so I don't think
that you can pick and choose when to
play by the rules and obviously it's
horrible right now when we see the
degree to which they don't play by the
rules
I understand saying it we would be
justified in not playing by the rules
here because we have to get them out I
think that that would be the wrong
instinct I believe the path forward
should be you've got to remove Trump in
November turn the Senate blue if not
this November in November of 2022 maybe
this terror of a presidency will affect
enough voters that it will sort of
predispose open up the country to accept
real change if the Democratic Party gets
the country back under control I'm no
fan of the Democratic Party as an
institution but you know there are
people who are going to seek to blame
Democrats here in fact I've seen some
so-called populist Sauveur the last week
finding as much to criticize of
Democrats
the context of the Trump Fiasco as they
find to criticize about Donald Trump
himself I think they're just wrong
the truth is Democrats for all of their
faults and there are many and I talk
about them all the time Democrats tried
to investigate Trump they saw facts
which pointed to impeachment being the
right remedy and they did it it didn't
matter the Republican Party was never
going to go for it we never believed for
a second that Trump was going to be
convicted on impeachment but the
Democrats saw the evidence and said
impeachment is the correct thing
Democrats were obstructed by the Trump
administration and by Republicans at
every turn so there are plenty of
critiques of the Democratic Party and I
make them all the time but right now
deflecting blame onto the Democratic
Party is the wrong move right now it's
the Republican Party under trumpism that
either participated in the attacks on
the rule of law or as they stood aside
as Trump did it himself and they need to
be held accountable as well that's very
important they are also to blame and you
primarily should be blaming the bad
actors so I'm not going to play coy with
that the way there are some people doing
New York maybe should look at
prosecuting Roger stone president can't
pardon or commute state sentences and
convictions so on the stone matter that
would be something to look at but big
picture we really can't miss the forest
for the trees right now if you're
wondering where is dr. Anthony foul gee
where has he been lately he has not been
talking to Donald Trump that we know dr.
foul she has been less and less
frequently seen publicly but we've now
learned that dr. foul she has not
briefed Donald Trump on coronavirus in
two months has been dissuaded from doing
too many public interviews by the Trump
administration and if you're surprised
by this you've just not been paying
attention months ago the Trump
administration stopped the coronavirus
press briefings especially after the
entire look at injecting bleach and
alcohol Fiasco the Donald Trump was
involved in and for all intents and
purposes they've decided this is a
political decision not a medical one
they've decided the pandemic is over
we're reopening now if there are embers
we will put them out we've done the best
testing and the most testing and we've
got therapeutics and vaccines are going
well and all of this stuff
pouchy signals you know I don't know
that
are going that well he says I'm speaking
to Trump less and less frequently I'm
briefing Trump less and less frequency
frequently Trump takes on the language
of victory and we just see dr. Anthony
Fauci almost completely disappeared in
the last 10 days doctor foul he starts
being really clear we're not doing well
we're headed towards a hundred thousand
cases per day we had 71 thousand cases
per day a few days ago we're not
handling this correctly if you look at
other countries and you look at us it's
clear that things aren't going well so
what is the outcome the outcome of
pouchy telling the truth is that the
Trump administration and the White House
try to stop vouches TV appearances this
is the stop testing to stop cases
mentality we want to have a lower case
number just stop testing as much and our
cases will go down don't like what
Anthony foul fee is saying just don't
let him say it it won't change whether
we're headed to a hundred thousand cases
a day but at least you won't hear it
from foul Qi it's like saying you know
if we didn't do any pregnancy tests we
wouldn't have any unintended pregnancies
because we just wouldn't have the tests
and of course the reality is Trump
failed the administration failed the
world has stopped laughing at us now
they're crying they are they are
horrified by what they are seeing here
and you know it's like we look around
the world do we understand by we I mean
that does our government understand why
South Korea still doesn't have 300 total
deaths and we're having seven hundred to
a thousand a day it's because they took
this seriously it's because they
developed a test and rolled it out
quickly they did contact tracing they
isolated people with symptoms everybody
wears a masks why does Japan have under
a thousand deaths total despite having a
population of 125 million people and
being geographically close to the
virus's origin in China it's because
they took it seriously and everybody's
wearing masks and it's not just the
public facing dismissals of pouchy that
are concerning again he hasn't briefed
Trump in two months and he hasn't even
spoken to Trump since early June the
White House publicly has
turned on foul Qi they've put out
statements lately saying you know we're
concerned because foul Qi has gotten a
bunch of things wrong they even took the
time to put together a list of things
foul Qi has been wrong about things from
early in the pandemic like when doctor
foul she said there probably isn't much
a symptomatic spread and of course this
is a fallacy this is a novel coronavirus
everybody got things wrong the people
who said no one would die got things
wrong Trump saying we have 15 cases
which will go to zero that was wrong the
difference is fout she corrects himself
as science does since it has a built-in
error correcting mechanism Trump never
apologizes Trump never corrects himself
he never admits that he was wrong that's
the danger and none of this is
surprising I mean at this point there
are almost as many conspiracy theories
floating around about doctor foul Qi as
there are about Bill Gates and it's not
a big shocker that all of a sudden Trump
is no longer listening to doctor foul Qi
the only chakras foul she hasn't been
fired now
we could if we wanted to criticize
doctor foul Qi we could say he was too
soft on Trump early he shouldn't have
sugar-coated the job the administration
was doing early but I get the logic if
out she just straight up calls out from
early and sounds the alarm says Red
Alert
this guy's incompetent he's failing he
probably gets fired right away and
there's a calculus to be made does a
sort of restricted foul Qi but in a
position of power give us a better
outcome than foul Qi being fired and
replaced with some total trump sycophant
I don't know the answer I get it foul Qi
likely made the call that he thought was
the best in the net it's not easy but
one argument would be foul she has
effectively been fired anyway in the
sense that he's been sidelined he
doesn't talk to trunk Trump and he's
dissuaded from doing interviews I'm not
pretending to know the answer one last
thought I tweeted recently we all know
that eventually when it's over they'll
try to blame foul Chi and not Trump in
some of the sickest revisionist history
you can imagine I tweeted that early
this weekend the reality is it's already
happening it's already happening and
when we you know they say the winners
get to write history
who are the winners here if people keep
dying and dying and dying I don't know
and we can't allow them to revise
history in that way we'll continue
covering this on our Instagram page
follow the david pakman show on
instagram at david pakman show and
follow me while you're there I ran into
an entitled guy yesterday in Boston and
I called him out and I filmed it and
it's on my Instagram page okay I'm half
kidding but I'm serious as well David
Pakman on the David Pakman show at david
pakman.com the david pakman show depends
on the support of our viewers and
listeners and one way to keep us going
is through patreon where you can pledge
as little as one dollar per month or as
much as you want at patreon.com slash
david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well read about him
[Music]
welcome back to the David Pakman show I
think many of you are going to enjoy
this one even if it is horrifying so a
few weeks ago Sean Hannity hosted Donald
Trump in a a big Town Hall they made a
big deal out of it people in the crowd
were allowed to ask questions it was set
up as a complete softball just to make
Donald Trump look good and he looked
terrible
the questions were were super simple
questions we covered this and it was
notable because even easy questions
Trump failed on he was asked questions
like what were your biggest
accomplishments in your first term what
is on your priority list for your second
term and Trump failed on every single
one of these softball questions now just
as a reminder here is Trump asked what
are your top second term priorities he
couldn't name anything this was a couple
weeks ago if you hear 131 days from now
at some point in the night or early
morning we can now project Donald J
Trump has been reelected the 45th
President of the United States let's
talk how'd it what's at stake in this
election as you compare and contrast and
what is one of your top priority items
for a second term well one of the things
that will be really great you know the
word experience is still good I always
say talent is more important that
experience I've always said that but the
word experience is a very important word
it's in a very important meeting I never
did this before I never slept over in
Washington I was in Washington I think
17 times all of a sudden the president
the United States you know the story of
riding down Pennsylvania Avenue with our
first lady and I say this is great but I
didn't know very many people in
Washington wasn't my thing I was from
Manhattan from New York now I know
everybody and I have great people in the
administration you make some mistakes
like you know an idiot like Bolton all
he want to do is drop bombs on everybody
you don't have to drop bombs on
everybody you have to kill people John
Bolton in fact released classified
material should he be prosecuted yeah oh
absolutely well he did release
classified well Trump was given another
chance in another soft ball Sean Hannity
interview a few days
ago and he was asked the same question
and he had weeks to prepare a better
answer and he still failed Trump was
told by Hannity during the interview you
know a lot of people didn't like your
answer last time what are your second
term priorities and Trump goes on for
two minutes and says almost nothing
again he got the test again he already
had the test questions he answered one
way he gets the same test again and he
fails take a look let's what is your
second term agenda well first of all I
didn't I was criticized for that answer
because it's a simple question first
we're going to defeat the the invisible
enemy and that's that will well it our
way and as again I told you the
mortality rate is 10 fold down we're
going to rebuild the economy we're going
to bring back jobs from all of these
foreign lands that have stolen our jobs
or horrible trade deals we're going to
continue to make great trade deals we're
going to finish rebuilding our wall
we're going to finish we're going to
have that it's going to be almost
complete by the end of this year shortly
thereafter it's finished it's made a
tremendous difference you see we're
doing record numbers on the border very
few people are able to get through we're
rebuilding with our military we've
rebuilt the military two point five
trillion dollars we're fixing up the VA
for our vets what the job we've done
there between choice and accountability
we have choice where they have with they
can go out and get a doctor if they're
sick they don't have to wait for five
weeks six weeks two weeks so we're doing
great with the vets and the vets are
loving Trump we're protecting our Second
Amendment so important we need more
judges and more justices you see that
now with the Supreme Court more than
ever and the next president I've had two
and the next president is going to be
able to pick two or three or one or
whatever but a lot of justices and that
means everything whether it's for life
or other things I mean it's mean so much
but protecting the Second Amendment
getting more judges all of the things
that we've done nobody has done what
this administration has done in the
first three and a half years nobody's
even come close when you look at
everything that would now what we're
doing
working on lowering drug prices and
knocking out special interest because
it's not easy we're fighting for choice
we did it for the veterans now we're
doing it for school too we're one choice
in school so a parent can take their
child to a school of their choice and
that's happening very good very very
well and we have many things that we're
doing and many things that we've already
completed and you can't do more than
what we've done I think we've set
records on every we've actually set a
record on judges we're going to be by
the time of the end of this year we'll
be up to almost 300 so go through the
list of what from said he says my
priority is to defeat coronavirus we've
had one of the worst responses in the
world and when it's defeated ultimately
it'll have nothing to do with Donald
Trump it'll be because of medical
science he says he's gonna rebuild the
economy it's vague and meaningless
that's a vague and meaningless promise
he says he's gonna bring jobs back from
places that stole them I thought he
already dealt with fixing trade with his
tariffs and USMC a he's saying oh so he
hasn't actually done that says he's
gonna build the wall and that it'll be
almost complete within the year that's a
lie and remember he promised to build
the full us-mexico border wall during
the first term obviously it's not going
to happen obviously it wouldn't happen
during a second term he again brings up
we're gonna rebuild the military the
military's huge the military's fine the
military was fine under Barack Obama
there's no problem with the military he
again says he's going to keep fixing the
VA for veterans like with veterans
choice that was an Obama provision
that's an Obama program from 2014 which
Trump is taking credit for but he said
that he did that in the first term isn't
it aren't we done doing that so that's
incoherent says he's going to protect
guns he mentions that twice he's done
nothing as far as that goes
says he's going to lower drug prices and
kick out the special interest that
sounds great the problem is he promised
that for term one and did the opposite
he says school choice
that's terrible in its code for take
funding away from from public education
and then again he mentions judges three
times now that's a reason to remove
Trump and to take control of the Senate
back from Republic
but getting judges confirmed the Senate
does that it's Mitch McConnell who did
that no matter which Republican
president you had as vacancies come up
they nominate people it's up to the
Senate to go ahead and confirm them so
if your second term agenda is the same
vague stuff as what you did in the first
term or claimed you were going to do but
failed why do you deserve a second term
it's another one of these vapid words
salads and I actually listen I worry I
know that part of the problem is that a
lot of voters hear that two minute clip
and they think Trump outlined an agenda
like this is an educational problem an
agenda would be Trump saying or you know
a candidate saying I have detailed
proposals on my website but to sum up
some of my main priorities for the
second term are in the next four years I
want to establish a public healthcare
option and drop the Medicare age to 55 I
will be establishing three new tax
brackets at 40 to 45 and 48 percent the
money which comes from that will be used
to do green infrastructure spending the
details of which I specifically outline
on my website in a proposal but it
includes retrofitting all government
buildings to certain standards it
includes increasing the number of the
percentage of energy that we use to be
generated from these three renewables so
whatever right well put us back in Paris
climate and the w-h-o that's something
that sounds like an agenda what Trump
said is not anything and one of the real
problems is I don't want to say people
are stupid but there's a lot of stupid
people and when I did a segment just
saying we've got to realize a lot of
people are stupid many people don't
realize that Trump didn't even outline
an agenda like that the problem is a lot
of folks are evaluating what Trump said
to say do I like this agenda or don't
don't I like it he didn't outline an
agenda and a lot of trumps followers
don't realize that it's an educational
issue at its core you know one of the
things that you maybe don't want to say
if you're trying to convince other
people about how cognitively stable you
are is to make a completely outlandish
claim like doctors who gave me a cognate
tests were shocked at how well I did on
it
that's essentially exactly what Donald
Trump said to Sean Hannity on Fox News
the other night during the same
interview in which he failed to answer
the same questions from a few weeks ago
a second time so let's look at the clip
and then discuss it he didn't mean that
because he hasn't taken any cognitive
test because he couldn't pass one I
actually took one when I very recently
when I when I was you know the radical
left was saying is you all there is you
all there and I proved that was all
there because I asked it I aced the test
and he should take the same exact test
the very standard test I took took it at
Walter Reed Medical Center in front of
doctors and they were very surprised
they said that's an unbelievable thing
rarely does anybody do what you just did
but he should take that same test but
now he has been totally taken over is
the constant bragging about really odd
things wearing anybody else down and
there's a lot to break down here but as
usual aside from from Trump lying all
the time when Trump goes hyperbolic you
can be extra sure that he's lying
doctors were surprised rarely does
anybody do what I did on a cognitive
test what and the whole context of this
is that the right is trying to frame Joe
Biden as having dementia we on the Left
have had concerns about Trump's
cognitive state for years and we don't
know whether it's related to cognitive
decline in the form of early stage
Alzheimer's or dementia side effect of
some prescription medication drug use
there's a lot of many many different
ideas going on and there's many examples
that point to this the verbal glitches
that coincide with the shoulder spasms
Trump not recognizing Rudy Giuliani when
Giuliani was right in front of him Trump
talking about the oranges of an
investigation Trump getting off of Air
Force One in front of his car and
wandering off and having to be brought
back by a Secret Service agent from
having to be helped down the ramp after
his West Point speech dozens and dozens
of these and what they're doing is try
to turn trying to turn it back on Biden
saying Biden sounds lost he doesn't know
where he is he's hiding from the
campaign trail in his basement because
of cognitive decline Biden recently said
I'm fine and I've been tested they
reacted by saying why would Biden be
tested for cognition and yet now Trump
is saying I've been tested and I did
incredibly well on my cognitive test he
even was given a lollipop on the way out
and was able to get a second scoop of
ice cream that night what test is he
referring to first of all we don't know
if Trump is referring to the Montreal
cognitive assessment as far as we know
he got that test a couple of years ago
this is a simple test 30-point test that
takes ten minutes it's really only good
for identifying very serious issues with
basic memory recall an executive
function and just being oriented in time
in place so the 30 points come from for
example the clock drawing task you get
three points I would say to you draw a
clock and show me what the hands look
like when it's 6:15 that you get three
points for that copy not even draw from
memory copy a three-dimensional cube
that's a point I would ask you where are
we right now and what's today's date
that's 20% of the score you have to
identify three animals okay so if that's
the test Trump is referring to he took
it a long time ago and it doesn't really
tell us very much claiming to have aced
it is like saying you know I a s--t a
colonoscopy right like these are
screening tools for serious cognitive
decline and it wouldn't rule out any of
what's being explored with Donald Trump
now to go back to I took it recently at
Walter Reed that's actually a part of
this that's not being discussed as far
as we've been informed Trump hasn't gone
to Walter Reed for medical evaluation he
was there recently I think visiting
troops but he hasn't been to Walter Reed
for medical care since that day last
year when he was weirdly rushed there
and Walter Reed said we didn't know he
was coming and what we were told was oh
he had a few hours free and we decided
to go and get him a jump on his 20/20
physical it wasn't believable then but
as far as we know that's the lot
Time Trump was there and as far as we
know he didn't get the Montreal
cognitive assessment that day it was
actually back in 2018 or even 2017 so
none of it makes sense none it's all
very concerning and again doctors have
never seen anything like my results on a
cognitive assessment it's the hyperbole
that immediately signals that Donald
Trump is lying let me know what you
think is behind all of this and remember
that you can get the David Pakman show
audio podcast for free this is available
to everybody every day on which ever is
your favorite podcasting platform if you
use the iPhone podcasts app beautiful if
you're on your desktop computer and you
like Spotify perfect it's available
everywhere make sure you're subscribed
for free to the daily podcasts to get
the full show every day
right around 3:00 p.m. Eastern the david
pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
whether you're looking for david pakman
show coffee for your Chemex or French
press or a David Pakman show t-shirt
it's all available on our website
shipping to anywhere in the world at
david pakman.com slash gear
don't miss the bumper stickers to david
pakman.com forward slash gear the david
pakman show at david pakman.com
the so Donald Trump is again defending
golfing this weekend even as multiple
states are hitting new single day highs
in terms of you coronavirus cases and
he's defending golfing with a really
strange rant about how it's his exercise
and anyway Obama played more golf which
isn't true and he's getting work done on
the golf course and he's rushing through
the holes anyway so that nobody should
really be mad it's bizarre but before we
get to it understand the context the
context is Trump has spent by one count
two hundred and seventy seven days on
the golf course during his presidency
that's twenty one point eight percent of
his presidency
and of the two hundred and seventy seven
days that he golfed on all but eight
meaning 269 he went to courses
he owns which is yet another way in
which he has handsomely profited from
the presidency funneling taxpayer money
your money my money into his courses by
requiring a full mobilization of
government and Secret Service two
resorts and golf courses that he owns so
that's one context the other context is
also that Donald Trump claimed during
Barack Obama's presidency that Obama
golf too much and that he wouldn't have
any time for golfing remember some of
this stuff because I'm gonna be working
for you I'm not gonna have time to go
play golf I love golf I think it's one
of the Great's but I don't have time and
I let go but if I were in the White
House I just want to stay in the White
House and work my ass off and then even
more specifically because there's a
tweet for everything Trump tweeted in
October of 2014 as the Ebola I can't
call it a pandemic as the Ebola
situation was going on which led to two
deaths in the United States Trump
tweeted quote can you believe that with
all of the problems and difficulties
facing the US President Obama spent the
day playing golf
worse than Carter so of course Trump
golf's all the time more than Obama when
not to but a hundred and thirty seven
thousand Americans have died from corona
virus and he tweets this
our defense of his golfing take a look
at this saying quote I know many in
business and politics that work out
endlessly in some cases to a point of
exhaustion it is their number one
passion in life but nobody complaints my
exercise is playing almost never during
the week a quick round of golf
Obama played more and much longer rounds
no problem when I play fake news CNN and
others park themselves anywhere they can
to get a picture then scream president
Trump is playing golf actually I play
very fast get a lot of work done on the
golf course and also get a tiny bit of
exercise not bad so does this require
analysis none of it makes sense
he first weirdly starts by saying some
people work out too much and they end up
tired I'm not going to do that now I
don't think anybody mistakenly thought
Trump was going to work out so much that
he'd be he'd be overtired from it I
think we knew that but he says golfing
is actually his exercise now of course
he drives a golf cart around so the
exercise part is actually pretty limited
walking nine holes with your clubs
walking 18 holes with your clubs it's
really very good exercise Trump doesn't
do that but then he adds in I'm not
playing during the week only on weekends
but in any case Obama golf more than I
did which is untrue
but in any case he's playing really fast
so he's not spending that much time on
the golf course and he's getting a lot
of work on the golf course so this is
about four or five different arguments
some of which conflict with each other
but most importantly he told us he
wasn't going to have time for golf and
these are not normal times we have a
global pandemic which he has handled
worse than almost anybody than any other
world leaders and he's not only spending
time golfing he's spending time tweeting
about golfing now the counter-argument
is one I've made before which is Trump
fails that the things he works on so
don't we want like if he golfed all the
time maybe coronavirus handling would be
left to people who are competent but we
know that's not how it actually works
when he's gone it's that lunatic Peter
Navarro and you know whoever else it's
it's not doctor foul Qi
runs the show when Trump is golfing and
putting aside the human toll of
coronavirus for a moment that's that's
the most important thing from a
political standpoint many presidents
would have jumped at a pandemic as a way
to secure their reelection I've said
this before if Donald Trump had properly
handled coronavirus if Trump said at the
beginning we are going to do the best on
this I am going to get reelected for how
well I'm going to handle this Trump
could have an almost guaranteed
re-election one of the areas on which
Biden is crushing Trump the most is
perceptions of handling of coronavirus
if Trump had handled that well Biden
would not be leading the way that he's
leading right now Trump would need no
October Surprise if he simply managed
this properly that's mind-blowing to
think about because as usual Trump's
problems are mostly self-inflicted the
virus is not self-inflicted but look at
New Zealand right you have a
historically popular leader there
because of how she dealt with the virus
she didn't cause the virus but she
handled it Donald Trump hasn't and it's
yet another one of these partially
self-inflicted disasters for Donald
Trump hey here's just whacky video
Wisconsin Republican state senator Glenn
Grothman is not big on masks and he
introduced Donald Trump at the Wisconsin
State Republican convention on Saturday
masks were of course optional only a few
masks in the crowd of hundreds of people
Glenn showed up after tweeting pictures
of himself out and about earlier in the
day not wearing a mask of course he
shows up and he tries to introduce
Donald Trump and he immediately goes
into an uncontrollable coughing fit the
cough racking his entire body the way
coronavirus is known to do I believe at
one point you actually hear someone's
someone shout from the crowd are you
okay you have to see it to believe it he
actually has to start loosening his tie
because of the degree to which he's
coughing violently it's time to talk
about Donald J Trump
[Applause]
okay yep okay guys this is how
coronavirus spreads I'm not saying he
has coronavirus but it spreads when
anti-mask people are around other people
all day and then they're coughing in
public I'm not saying that cough I don't
know how close people were sitting maybe
that cough doesn't give it to anybody
but Wisconsin is increasingly in trouble
if you look at their case numbers cases
are spiking hitting their highest
seven-day moving average today with four
days in a row of record high cases now
the event organizers are saying or they
said earlier if you have symptoms you
shouldn't go the event organizers said
we will make available face masks for
people who want them almost nobody wore
a mask in comes this guy and he's
coughing uncontrollably
you really can't fix stupid and this is
why we aren't making progress and I know
people I already said it people are
going to write and say David the you
know this guy probably doesn't have
corona virus layer one is even having
this event you just shouldn't have this
event there's no reason to have this
event right now layer two if you have
the event require than asks say that the
mass are required
I guess that's considered taking away
people's freedoms on the Republican side
and then layer three is this specific
guy coughing uncontrollably
he's an invited speaker not wearing a
mask and he's setting the model that
it's okay to be going around in public
coughing with no mask it's stunning
stunning idiocy the likes of which we
hopefully will never see again in
leadership in this country Trump finally
wore a mask over the weekend and I hope
to talk about that tomorrow but you know
the the Trump people are now they're all
over the place on Trump wearing the mask
the people who think masks aren't
necessary don't know how to react
because Trump now is wearing one is
Trump stupid to wear it then there's the
people who think that the masks or
something the left is bullying people
into if they see from wearing it by
definition
must not really be that alpha because he
was bullied by the left into wearing a
mask if Trump insists the pandemic is
over why did he just now start wearing a
mask like his followers are completely
flummoxed by Trump wearing the mask but
this is all part of the big picture it's
setting a model for what it is that
people should and shouldn't be doing and
Glenn Grothman here hacking
uncontrollably not good not good
whatsoever we have a voicemail number
that number is two one nine two david p
here's a voicemail with a question about
the future which i think is not a
question we should really think about
too much you'll know what i mean when
you hear it hi David um I thought you
probably won't listen to this but um I
was just wondering what you think the
chances are of Trump being put behind
bars after he yeah if he loses this
election I was curious on your thoughts
as he will face criminal charges for
everything that he's done to this
country yeah I do not believe that
Donald Trump is going to spend any time
behind bars and I think we should stop
thinking about it you know from the
beginning
if something happens okay it is not
common that former American presidents
go to prison I understand that Donald
Trump is a new animal and he has done
things no president has done but when
the Moller investigation started I was
reminding people this is not going to
remove Trump the the soonest opportunity
will be November 3rd 2020 when
impeachment started I said this is
correct but it is not going to remove
Trump the quickest way to remove him is
going to be November 3rd 2020 and I
don't believe that there is prison time
waiting for Donald Trump on the tail end
of this presidency and I don't believe
that we should be waiting for it we have
one opportunity to remove Trump and the
consequence he will face is losing
re-election and having his ego very very
triggered and that is voting on November
3rd of 2020 so I understand the instinct
I get it all I really do
let's focus on getting the vote out
rather than talking about might Trump
end up in prison
tomorrow night Tuesday July 14 the third
ever David Pakman show chess tournament
the first tournament had 500 players the
second tournament had 738 732 players
let's try to beat it tomorrow you can
register for free at david pakman.com
slash chess let me actually see as of
right now we have 168 players registered
all levels of chess skill including no
skill are very much welcome it's a
community building event I hope you will
join me I also have a really interesting
chess related announcement coming up
sometime later this week and tomorrow
Tuesday we will have a big one-day
membership special early in July because
of the virus about 300 members who
signed up in 2019 had to cancel their
memberships they weren't able to renew
because of financial circumstances so we
are trying to dig out of a 300 member
hole and in order to do that tomorrow
we're doing a big one-day membership
drive to be notified simply get on my
newsletter at david pakman.com you'll
see in the upper right of the website
you can type in your email address and
then you will be notified of tomorrow's
big membership special on today's bonus
show which is of course a membership
perk we are going to talk about the
truth about what's going on with the
border wall I do want to address the
situation going on with the goya CEO and
a lot of the really dumb takes that
we're hearing from some people on the
right and then just days after the owner
of the Washington Redskins said they
would never change their team name they
are expected to change their team name
it may even have been announced by the
time you hear this so all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
get instant access at david pakman.com
slash membership and for the latest
updates from the urban garden simply
follow me on instagram at david pakman
I'll see you on the bonus show or
otherwise tomorrow